Hi, my boy!
Hello, everybody, welcome back.
We are on part six.
Six of the Portal 2.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, last time there was so much goo.
And I'm excited for even more goo in this time.
I'm like trying to drink my tea.
And I've put too much water.
So it's like...
Super overflowing.
Okay.
As you can hear, my voice is still a little bit...
Respey.
Um...
This is the same as last time, so...
Sorry about that.
But...
Uh...
Yeah, hopefully it's not too much of a bother.
Let's continue!
I'm loving this area.
Oh, oh, yeah, white goo, baby!
Oh, my God.
I think I just solved my own issue.
I was like, how do I get the goo to go other places?
I did it unintentionally.
Um, I like the white goo because it makes it so that you can
goop out a side of areas.
Oh, I'm getting splashed.
Oh, I'm in the splash zone.
Wait a second.
Can I do it like here?
Wait, hold on.
Right there.
Too close.
There we go.
Spread it that way.
Dang, we're like already into the puzzle.
There's so much.
I feel like I didn't even get a second to...
Okay, let's...
Not enough goo.
Oh.
We're just, I'm just shooting it everywhere.
Don't say that.
Sorry.
So sorry.
I didn't mean it like...
I am.
I mean, I am, though.
I'm shooting the goo.
Everywhere.
Can I go through?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
I am.
I, you know, I'm just getting it all over.
Everywhere will be portable.
Trust.
Oh my gosh.
I'm making a bit of a mess.
Now that I can escape.
Let's do like here.
And here.
And let's get... Oh.
Wrong way.
Can we do like so?
There we go, there we go.
Oh, not quite.
Close, close, close.
Close.
Trying to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I feel like that will be important, no?
Alright, let's see what we got going on over here.
Where am I supposed to be going to?
Is the big question.
I'm covering places in goo, and I have no idea where I need
to.
Goo!
Oh, I know everybody's typing plus two right now.
And if you're booing, don't forget I'm a ghost.
And that's a great compliment to me.
Let's see.
Over there, perhaps somehow.
I must find a way to get up there.
How can I...
Can we get much higher?
I'm just looking around.
There's a lot going on here, isn't there now.
Okay.
It's kind of, like, insane.
It's, like, such a powerful thing to be able to...
a portal wherever I wish kind of OP maybe oh
wrong way let's do like here ah I'm in the splash zone oh
I'm in the splash zone I'm lost too alright there we go
there we go alright let's get out of this This is the goop
for a bit.
If I launch myself from here, it's not quite a launch, but I
do wish to see how far I go.
How far I'll go?
Not very far.
It calls me.
Okay, this is, I think, actually, it might be a more
difficult puzzle.
Because the world becomes...
so much more open.
This is where we came from.
Everything becomes so much crazier because we can create
where we want the portals to be.
It ends up becoming even crazier than you imagine because
you know, when you're given kind of the areas that...
Oops.
I went the wrong way again.
When you're given the areas that you...
know you can portal into it you know makes you makes you
able to kind of set up do the setup a little bit better you
know what i mean like you could be like okay so i have to
utilize this area but in this kind of situation you're like
no it's all your brain which i guess makes it so that you
can come up with you know not everyone's way will be the
same which is pretty cool too.
I suppose.
Oh, what if I do this?
Kind of...
Oh, keep angling it upwards and upwards.
Until we get to the tipy top.
And then I can portal up there!
Yes, yes, yes!
Well, actually,
All right.
Huh.
Okay.
I might need to...
Dang it.
Okay.
Let's see if we can do this.
I don't like having to angle it, though.
It's kind of frustrating.
But it's just annoying.
And, uh...
No, I can't go down anymore.
Okay.
We'll just have to...
Get it all in this area.
Goop it all up.
So what we'll do is we'll have a portal down there.
Fall and launch to up there.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, yeah.
Very good.
Should be good.
Oh, was that it?
Oh, I've been thinking.
when life gives you lemons don't make lemonade make life
take the lemons back yeah yeah what am I supposed to do with
these the man to see life's manager make life rule the day
give cave Johnson lemons do you know who I am I'm the man
who's gonna burn your house down with the lemon I'm gonna
get my engineers to invent a combustible lemon that burns
your house down finding people he says what we're all
thinking the point is if we can store music on a compact
disc why can't we store a man's intelligence and personality
on one so I have the engineers figuring that out now brain
mapping is artificial intelligence we should have been
working on 30 years ago I will say this and I'm gonna say it
on tape so everybody hears it a hundred times a day if I die
before you people can pour me into a computer I want I want
Carolyn to run this place.
Is Gladys Carolyn?
She'll say she can't.
She's modest like that.
But you make her.
Yeah, put her in my computer.
I don't care.
Alright, test's over.
You can head on back to your desk.
Goodbye, sir.
That's why...
That's how... That's why when...
When...
Uh, he said something earlier.
Uh, it was like in the last part.
He said something and GLaDOS repeated what Carolyn said.
Oh my god, she's Carolyn.
So she's not just like some random AI.
She's like this lady's consciousness.
Thank you for volunteering.
Hmm.
I do wonder if any of these doors are like secret doors.
Thank you for volunteering.
Please return to your desk.
gonna wait for other opportunity opportunities it's
hilarious seeing
this place in its heyday would be crazy though oh I can zoom
view again I forgot about or rather not again but it's
telling me about it what have we got here this is the
elevator it's stuck up there oh oh what the hell am I about
to be doing
Oh, uh, I see it up there, though.
Oh, there are rooms and stuff in here, too.
How fun.
Who's working in this area?
This is...
This is Cheeks.
Oh my god!
But you know, at least you're not alone.
You get to work in this area with some other poor chump.
Oh, man.
All right.
Maybe like up there.
I know.
It's like, hey, zoom, bozo.
Well, I'm working on it.
What's over here?
Oh, just a window.
And it shows.
I forgot about the zoom-in feature.
I'm glad that it doesn't handhold you.
But it does be like, hey, you might have forgotten about
this thing.
So we're just going to remind you real quick.
Which I appreciate.
Especially for myself.
Oh, gosh.
Did I come up?
I think we can get higher.
Can we get much higher?
Yeah.
Okay.
And it's right there.
Whoa, be careful, be careful.
There we go.
I don't think there was anything else in that room.
Oh!
Are we gonna wanna bring this down?
And like, oh my gosh, fall from the top?
Or something!
Okay.
It's not letting me...
There's no butt in the press, so...
Surely.
There's not anything to do.
Hooray!
Oops.
Oops!
My bad.
I'm a man
Oh Okay That just seems to be another window I was curious
what it was It does not seem to be of anything important
Actually Do you think I can make that?
You suck it now we're on ground.
That's just another window.
3,000 meters.
Tee.
All right.
And it's this window again.
Yeah, the one that shows that doorway.
All right.
That was my bad, everybody.
I claim fault there.
All right.
We're basically...
back where we were.
Sorry if I take a bunch of water breaks.
Let's see.
Hey!
No, not again, not again!
Not again!
Okay, we're fine.
How, though, do I like...
Huh!
Hey!
Unless...
I am supposed to do that.
I am supposed to fall.
What do I do if I'm here, though?
Oh, dang it.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
We were close.
Oh, no.
Thanks, Shadow.
Oh, wait.
I was right.
I don't know why I did that.
I thought I had to realign it.
What?
Please, please, please, please.
Oh.
Okay.
Maybe there's something else that I need to see.
Let me go up there and turn around and stuff.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Orange.
Alright.
We made it?
I'm stuck.
I'm not stuck.
Uh.
I'm here.
What do I do here now?
Is the ever so valuable question.
What everybody's asking.
Where do you go from?
From here.
I think I have to keep falling.
But.
Maybe.
Okay, let's.
Let's see.
That's where I was.
Okay.
Ah!
Okay, so it's gotta be.
Oh, what color?
Blue.
Whew!
Okay.
Oh my goodness gracious.
It's so disorienting.
We made it to another area.
I wonder if this is chapter 8.
Surely not, right?
It's too early.
these are one-way doors i know things look bleak but
going to march right back upstairs and make him put me back
in my body
no wow wow
get mad get mad okay so these are portalobalobal I hear.
I hear gel.
Oh, there it is.
I hear you.
I hear the gel.
My beloved gel.
I hear you.
Really?
That's not a...
Oh, I'm zooming in on everything.
Oh, wait.
Okay, what we need to do is launch ourselves.
Oh, wait, I think...
If I do this...
Yeah, okay, good.
Oh, dang it!
Oh, that's frustrating.
Very nice.
the landing.
That might have been an absolute perfect landing, actually.
I don't know where it's, okay, it's bouncing around
somewhere.
Where do I need it to bounce on to, though?
Where do I need it to bounce to?
Wow.
It's like suspended in midair almost.
For now, let's do like here.
Launching far and wide.
What if I do here?
Would this bounce me into anywhere, though?
If I did the same thing that I just did, you know what I
mean?
Hmm.
That is the winning question everybody's asking about.
I need to get up there.
I'm just trying to find like a pathway open.
Oh wait!
Right here!
Wait, would it bounce me up in there?
Oh okay, let's try the same thing that we did last time
then.
Oh shoot.
Yes!
Yippee!
Caution.
This color in particular is extremely half-life, no?
Can I?
Yes.
Hello?
My ghoul?
Did it stop?
It was dripping from here!
Who stopped it?
Wait, that's kind of creepy.
all right hold on i have to do some crazy maneuvering here
no but i don't think i can get in through here actually no i
think about it it's all like how do i get in
that's like barred up and stuff
look how high it goes you really just have to wonder how
people got around this place before, right?
I mean, I know it's like really old at this point, but,
golly.
Most of the stuff is still working, so...
I guess I... can try.
What?
There's this area here.
I don't think I'll be able to do it.
I mean, it's not very hard getting over here, back up here
anyway, so let's just, let's just try it, I suppose.
Oh, oh, I think I made it.
I did!
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
Man, sometimes the new perspective makes all the
All right, we got all three goos.
Crazy.
Is there a place I can go?
Splatter around?
Anywhere?
No?
Oh, here.
Oh, okay, okay.
Splatter on the ceiling.
Splatter on the ground.
Splatter all around.
Just a little bit There's a little bit of goo Oh, their goos
are fighting Oh my gosh, it's Splatoon
Is this one?
Oh, it is Aha Okay, okay, okay
Which then makes it so you can do that And also That That
Wait, where am I splattering it to?
Okay, up there.
Alright, and also this.
Oh, sorry, Blue Goo.
Okay, which then makes it you could do this.
And then this.
And then kind of scooch it over.
We're just splattering it everywhere.
Oh, shoot.
Did I get it up?
No.
Right there.
idiot i'm an idiot oh my gosh wait uh-oh uh-oh
what i was trying to do was get the blue up there but it's
like launching it you know so uh let's see
because like obviously i need to like probably run and
bounce over but i have to do it so correctly because
otherwise then I'll have to
re-white goo everything because the covering it with the new
goo will make it unportalable so it's a little frustrating
so this one would be this one down here but how can I get
the blue up here without being launched you know what I mean
Let's see.
Fight orange like here.
Oh, come on.
Is this goo not working?
Oh, it is.
It is, it is, it is.
Properly doing its job.
This stuff is getting everywhere.
How do I get the blue?
Alright.
Oh!
Well, I was gonna say I can bounce from here, but I still
need to...
You know, I still need to bounce from there to there.
Maybe...
Maybe I should have done the white one first.
Uh...
Or the, like, the blue one?
I do it like this.
Okay, so then...
Splatter, splatter, splatter!
Splatter, splatter!
I don't know if I can do this with this, but...
Oh, dang it!
I don't think it would work anyway.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I wouldn't have...
If only I could, like, get it right on there, you know what
I mean?
How can I dodge it?
Like, my first order should be trying to figure out this
guy.
There's nothing else.
That's just gonna launch it that way.
Oh, the way.
Holy cow.
Okay, what
if I time it to launch?
What if it's like here?
Or, wait, how would I do that?
Um...
Do you guys see my vision?
Maybe?
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, so right there, it's so fast, though.
I feel like this isn't it, but...
I feel like it's not.
Got it.
Oh, no!
It just goes up!
Ugh.
Wait, oops, wrong one.
It just goes up.
Let's just, uh, let's see what happens if I cover this and
then, you know, we go from here.
Maybe I could put a portal here and it will launch me
somewhere else.
For now, I'll just do that.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Arah!
Boing!
Oh, I tried the boing, but it didn't.
I wish I could...
You know, I wish I could, like, reset.
Okay, let's try.
It's like...
There's nothing happening.
Oh no, is this my one?
Is this my one to stop me?
No!
No, no!
Oh please!
I can't even get up there though.
So anyway...
Dang it.
There was an attempt.
There was an attempt at something.
Like it's really hard to do, so maybe I was wrong with the
run and jump.
Let's cover this all again.
Figure it out.
From the beginning.
I think it's because I'm so stuck in the method that I have
now that I'm like hmm there couldn't be another method my
method is the only right way that's clearly that's not the
case wait
is that up there oh I think I knew that one didn't I yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I knew about this one if we I don't
think I can run up a wall, but...
What if I bounce it?
Oh!
Wait.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh!
Guys, isn't this such a funny story?
Won't we be laughing about this later?
I know I will.
We'll be laughing about this later.
Dang.
Be thinking, ah, it's so funny!
Dang it.
Oh, it should be fine.
Okay, that should be fine.
All right, there we go.
Oh, no!
Please!
Oh, why?
What am I doing wrong?
It's like too little of splash to not...
to get any more.
I'm so close!
Please!
I
actually...
I wonder...
Can I just do this?
Oh, shoot.
It foils my plan.
We do want this not covered.
Or rather, not the bouncy.
Oh, sometimes the bouncy is bad.
No way.
It couldn't be.
Oh!
Where did it go?
Oh, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, so we'll do orange.
I don't...
I think I might have gotten the wrong one before.
Oh, oops!
Oops!
Wait.
Okay, I have to, like, be there?
Okay, okay.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I have to be locked onto it.
All right.
Oh, dang it.
I had it.
I had it, but I didn't.
Oh, why did I do that?
Wait.
I didn't.
Okay.
This might be a really weird way to do this.
I don't know.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't get...
Well, I didn't get the momentum anyway.
This is bizarre.
I feel like I'm not doing this right at all, but...
I need more momentum here.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I...
Okay, hold on.
Just a little down.
No, it stops here.
What I was going to try and do was launch the orange from
here.
But it doesn't work.
It does not work.
If I launch...
From here.
Oh my gosh, this one is getting me like bad.
Oh, whoops.
Hello, this is white.
Your own rules are not applying.
We're gonna try and get this area up.
This one's screwing me up.
Please!
Okay, here we go.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
It just doesn't want to get this area right here.
The game is sabotaging me.
Alright, I think I'm just gonna have to go back to my
original plan.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Which was... you.
And you.
Get it nice and everywhere.
Get nice and everywhere.
Oh, wow, it actually did hit a little bit.
I feel really stupid right now.
Oh, my God!
I didn't jump!
Alright, alright, alright.
Oops, oops, oops, there we go.
Oh, it, ah, yes, yes.
Okay, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange,
orange, orange, orange.
Where am I?
Oh, oh.
I'm getting kicked out.
I think I'm doing this, like, a really stupid way, but I
don't care.
Oh, I did it.
Somehow!
Where?
I did it!
Somehow!
And then we have this here.
Was this where I was?
before yes no I need to get over there okay okay okay I'm
all right I don't want to do that again I hated that I would
like to avoid it if possible I think I need to run and jump
again though maybe
do it here oh
Yeah, it doesn't even reach you.
Golly!
Having a time, huh?
Alright.
No, oh!
That's fine.
This one,
I don't know why it's wrong with my brain.
I feel like I wanna...
I wish I could...
I wish I could stop and give up!
Or like, not to give up, sorry.
That's the wrong word.
I wish I could stop and restart.
Like the whole thing.
The whole playthrough.
What the heck?
It's been so long.
I've been stuck on this stupid one for so stinking long.
We all win some.
We all lose some.
Oh, this is killing me though.
He's killing me.
this blue and i don't know what to do i have this blue and i
don't know what to do
no that's not what i wanted oh shoot
whoa it ended up becoming like a reverse did you guys see
that that was cool all right let's try this blue
Oh, I was like, where am I?
Wow, freaky.
No, please stop.
I'm like legitimately so I don't know.
I'm legitimately out of stinking laws for a lot of this.
People are probably like, be careful.
because this is where I came in from so I don't want to go
back down there obviously I have I'm working with the I feel
like I you know what I feel I feel cheated I praise the the
white gels so much I was like white goo is awesome yeah
white goo and now the white goo is killing me the white goo
is this is sabotaging me I fear
That goes up in there.
Can I...
Oh, whoops, I did the wrong one.
Can I hit to the end here?
Yes.
It doesn't...
It's like it doesn't reach up here.
What the heck is this?
This is really tough for me, you guys.
This is really tough for me.
And there's nothing up there, right?
No, I don't...
Not that I can see.
But we've gotten through all the other ones before.
We can make it through this one.
Two.
Whoa.
I'm going inside the pipe.
I'm becoming one with the goo.
It's like if I can jump from here.
But I don't really have anything to fling me that far.
So I'm wondering if I need to run, but I can't get it up
here.
You know?
This might be my longest episode.
We just tried to figure out this dang puzzle.
Let's
Oh!
There's more!
What do you mean?
What do you mean there's so much more?
What am I supposed to do with all of this?
Wait.
Oh, I felt this puzzle for a very, for way too long.
But it was right there in front of me.
Oh my god.
I am tired.
My fear, I cannot stop now.
Where'd this go?
Where the heck am I?
Oh my gosh, my brain feels blasted from that point.
Oh, golly!
Okay, alright.
I just was like, focus mode.
For a good bit.
Okay.
Oh wait, um, let's see.
Oh, uh...
Okay, there we go.
Phew, I was about to pit and say, um, I think we're in
trouble, but we're not.
Whoa!
It's getting everywhere!
It's spilling everywhere!
Wait, this is awesome!
It looks like a snowball fight.
It's kind of cute.
Wait, that was awesome.
This way up.
That's what we're working on.
What's in here?
Or if I do this.
If I do this.
Okay, it doesn't really get like the...
Let's see.
see what this is.
What can I see from here?
Nothing.
Alright.
I just want to, like, get out of this area, and then I will
feel more fulfilled.
Oh, I think I can drop from here.
Ow, actually.
Where am I?
I'm somewhere.
Watch your step.
Am I upside Down, what is this?
Sweep up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's just a really steep incline.
We're going forward.
We are going up, up, up, down, mom.
It's really steep.
Maybe I...
It's tripping me up so much because it doesn't look like
a...
You know, it doesn't look like...
Up.
Did I make it?
This looks like a new area.
Nobody is talking to me though.
I'm lonely.
Oh yeah.
Sorry, I mean, they're full.
Got a lot of stuff going on over here.
What's in here?
Anything?
Oh.
We keep
walking.
There's an exit up there.
I see her.
The walls...
need no goo.
The walls are fully portable.
I feel like one of these doors is gonna work, you know what
I mean?
Oh, there's a station over there.
Is that where I'm headed?
Oh, wait.
Actually, I just know, okay.
Classic.
Wait, I've got an idea.
A classic puzzle.
Paradoxes.
Oh.
I know how we can beat him.
Yeah.
Stand still.
Remain calm.
Scream.
This statement is false.
New mission.
Refuse this mission.
Does a set of that's contained itself?
Ugh.
That one hurts my brain.
Hatch!
Override!
Oh!
Whoa!
No.
Say they so, say it cannot be...
Is it...
The sunlight?
Oh.
This game is so me This game is so me Am I having to gel
now?
I have to go down.
there now I don't quite know how long this episode this part
is going to be because I don't know how much I'll edit it
but oh but
I guess you watching you'll know I think since we got
through it though Ooh, we're like a parking garage now.
Ooh.
That orange glowy over there.
Let's see it.
It's like all springs.
Everything is held up on springs.
Danger.
Keep out.
So cool.
Okay, so it's not the most watertight plan to go confronted
with.
Still, it's a better plan than exploding.
March to leave.
Oh!
This is a...
A...
A modern!
Oh, we're back to the modern!
What are the turrets doing with those cubes?
Chapter 8, The Itch Bay.
baby woohoo all right then i will call it here thank you
guys so so much we've oh my god i feel like the biggest
dummy dumbhead ever uh but i got through it and being here
is proof of that so yeah thank you guys for watching hanging
out with me see you in the next part Bye bye!
What's up, Mint?
Bye bye!